well sir ian wood who recently led that
review of North Sea oil and gas we were
hearing about joins me now from Aberdeen
Surrey and thank you for being with us
is this really a question of our ji
bhaji with you saying one thing and the
yes campaign saying another or can we
say with certainty that there is a limit
to the amount of oil which is going to
be got out each year going ahead and
therefore a limit on the amount of
revenue that will come from it sure well
you can't say with certainty because it
depends on the price of oil and the
range of technology development what you
can do with all the known facts right
now between the 12 and 24 billion
bottles at the high in the low end what
is the most likely and right now I
actually think that was pretty clear
Accord including al examined and as in
the recent Hollywood debate
acknowledging that the 15 to 16 which is
the the figure that I'd suggest is the
figure that Alec Kemp was a kind of
local guru has suggested is the right
figure at least up to 2050 very helpful
to VPN shell both coming up solidly
behind that today and saying that's
correct there's two issues what one is
at the 24 billion that is the Scottish
Government keep talking about is what
it's a third higher than what we believe
was correct but secondly and where I
think I've made a much more significant
contribution to debate if you look at
depletion and you cover that the figures
were covered in your the depletion over
the next 30 40 years and a Scottish
independence is forever so it's not just
this generation its future generations
then you are down to two hundred
thousand bottles a day as likely and I
don't think anyone's really disputing
that and in that basis we don't have any
significant oil and gas fiscal income
and therefore the gap has to be made up
with by a number of additional elements
in the scottish economy they've spoken
about higher productivity they've spoken
about Lord unemployment they spoken
about more manufacturing that's great
but there are in the realms then of
uncertainty and high risk and frankly I
think I think Scotland's to think very
hard and the basis of his future
generation of taking the chance and on
our own particularly with our industry
running downs been a 180,000 people
right now in Scotland employed by
so be quite a traumatic rundown taking
the chance or from doing it without the
candle wider support of the UK but you
see I've been speaking to leading
nationís politicians and one of the
thing they said to me with that man you
referred to as their oil guru says that
he's identified 99 new worlds and
therefore there could be more oil than
you're predicting but you see I came
into this debate because of distortions
and inaccuracies that's a complete spin
Alec Kemp had identified these 99
potential possible new discoveries in
the last three or four years and they
are built into our figures the figures
we've got just now have got up to five
billion battles of presently unfound oil
and gas that we hope to find that
includes the 99 fields and yet you get
this wonderful spin today as if it's all
new news and you bonanza it's completely
misleading the Scottish public do we
even know whose oil it is because
there's some suggestion that if you drew
the line but to into the oil fields
according to geography that actually
some of the southerly ones might end up
being in the rest of the UK's territory
rather than in Scotland's is there any
truth in that well the concerning thing
is there's going to be a massive
negotiation take place which will be
very hotly content I can't answer your
question because it'll have to be
decided by negotiation but the
unfortunate thing there at the very
critical time in the industry the
industry right now is going through a
really tough time we're talking about a
major fiscal review I eat more
incentives and my review my review came
up with a new regulator with a much
stronger regulator to get much more
collaboration that negotiation will take
place at a very unfortunate time and
that won't help we don't have the
answers that are right now it'll be very
very hard for an F on balance you had to
sum up the mood of the oil community
around aberdeen on balance not your
opinion but your assessment of the mood
would you say it's yes or no to
independence
I can't answer that question but what I
can answer is a more important question
in terms of implications I mean it's
quite clear both BP and shell made a
comment today that they would prefer
working within the bigger united kingdom
that is undoubtedly i interviewed
60-plus operating companies and over the
last 12 months and my maximize recovery
view there's no doubt not because if
anything against Scotland at all it's
got a very pleasant country to do
business in but because they prefer the
financial and economic strength of
working with the UK so undoubtedly there
is a real concern that if we make the
change then we will lose some investment
not just from present operators but for
new operators and that would be very
unhelpful